scorched debris from cars and
motorcycles cover a major artery on the
outskirts of freetown
and there are people here too
on the roadside and in the wreckage who
were caught in a catastrophic explosion
the cause of this devastating blast sits
in the middle of the road
the remnants of a lorry which crashed
into a fuel truck which would eventually
ignite
the tanker collided with the vehicle in
the early morning hours and fuel began
to spill from its chassis
some ran towards it trying to collect
what they could but they were killed
instantly when the truck went up
it's combustible contents lighting the
sky above the sierra leonean capital
many have suffered from horrific burns
with bystanders using homemade
stretchers to cart them away
and dozens and dozens of people have
died
the authorities say most of the dead
have been taken to the city's morgue but
they have not been able to release a
definitive death toll it's a very very
very busy junction so um the blast
actually
killed a lot of people there is not much
safety when they drive to
a major state in freetown there is none
um i have i drive in freetown and i'm
always worried about um field tankers
and um vehicles also carrying um you
know containers as well so um there's
there are no safety measures or
precautions that are given to people the
explosion in a teeming suburb has
stunned the city of one million
witnesses say a bus full of people was
completely burnt while shops and market
stalls were caught in the flames
when the head of the country's disaster
management agency visited the site he
said he'd never seen anything like it
john sparks sky news